my granddaughter  has been lost to us  i would have her return to me post taste  and you sir  i am told  of the man to do the job  each arm is equipped with an explosive  device your trousers are also equipped  with explosives  really  just beyond the point where we now stand  lies a highway where evil reigns  what is this at the end of five days if  you have not returned with bernice  well i think you get the idea son  godspeed  this is the ghostland  a land of no escape  we are not the ones who hold her captain  it's been two days  and still she is missing  how do i get out of here  you must surrender to fate  hi  radioactive  no one escapes the ghost left  i'm not a prisoner  you